et si la Caisse Primaire d'Assurance
Maladie changeait de nom pour s'appeler
caisse primaire d'assurance santé si au
lieu de rembourser les soins elle les
prévenait une idée toute simple mise en
place dans le département d'abord à
poissie et prochainement à Saint-Quentin
en Yveline c'est l'opération Santé
Active ouverte à tous les assurés
sociaux du régime général des ateliers
collectifs proposés autour de trois
thématiques le cœur le dos et la
nutrition il s'agit de proposer un
service de coaching en santé alors le
coaching en santé qu'est-ce que c'est en
fait c'est accompagner au quotidien des
personnes qui ne sont pas malades pour
préserver leur capitale santé c'est lié
effectivement à l'évolution des dépenses
de santé et aujourd'hui à des
pathologies qu'on voit croissantes par
exemple si on regarde la pathologie du
diabète on on voit qu'il y a une
augmentation croissante et les courbes
d'évolution montrent que d'ici à
quelques années le nombre de personnes
diabétiques pourra presque tripler à 50
ans yeline le dispositif est pour
l'instant expérimental les ateliers vont
démarrer à à partir du 6 novembre et des
inscriptions doivent se prendre les 18
et 30 octobre à l'Institut de promotion
de la santé à trpe partenaire de
l'opération c'est la prévention primaire
le but étant de passer des informations
générales à la base et de donner des
outils par le biais des ateliers avec
des on a des ateliers théoriques et des
ateliers pratiques donc justement des
mises en condition je passe je pense
surtout à l'activité physique où là par
contre la personne va être acteur
pendant son atelier ces ateliers de
prévention sont gratuits l'opération
Santé Active a été mise en place il y a
5 mois sur le territoire de poissie et
la CPM a enregistré 450 adhérents une
étude interne démontrerait qu'un tel
dispositif étendu à l'échelle nationale
pourrait permettre à l'Assurance Maladie
de réaliser 200 millions d'euros
d'économie